these drivers are on strike fuel prices
in Jordan have doubled in the past year
for many it's making life a daily
struggle
this Banner shows one word to sum up
their demands dignity
we joined the strike when we felt the
effects of the extremely high fuel
crisis High fuel prices mean higher
Transportation costs which in turn mean
a spike in prices of goods used by
jordanians
but while most rallies are peaceful
anger is growing
more and more people are joining the
protests often resulting in
confrontations with the police
on Thursday a senior police officer was
killed in Mount Province shot in the
head during a demonstration
the king attended the funeral a show of
support for security forces dozens of
officers have been injured in recent
unrest
the government has promised a zero
tolerance approach to violence
we are dealing with the situation and we
won't spare any effort to crack down on
whoever destabilizes public order we are
required by law to uphold our
responsibilities and duties to preserve
public security
protesters want taxes on fuel canceled
but with global Energy prices soaring
since Russia's invasion of Ukraine the
government says it's doing all it can
it spent around 700 million dollars
capping fuel prices this year
it's also promised financial aid to
vulnerable families but these protesters
say that's made very little difference
and if conditions don't improve the
unrest is likely to grow
Vincent Monaghan Al Jazeera